filmmaking is a director's medium he is
the captain of the ship but he also
needs a good crew first-class writers
good editors understanding technicians
and a host of others and it certainly
does not hurt him to have a chanela
McCain or a Walter Matthau to direct so
here to present a best directors award
are to direct his dreams a Shirley
MacLaine and a Walter Matthau
those nominated for best achievement in
directing are George Lucas for American
Graffiti Ingmar Bergman for cries and
whispers William Friedkin for The
Exorcist
Bernardo Bertolucci for Last Tango in
cash and George Roy hill for the sting
winner is George Roy
thank you all very much
I'd like to thank the members of the
Academy I also have a bit of advice for
my fellow directors and that's next time
out get a script by David Ward get a
cameraman like the great Bob Surtees yet
Marian Doherty to do your casting for
you that might include a Bob Shaw and
pull in a couple of ringers like Newman
and Redford and it helps believe me
thank you very much